salut et joyeux 11 juillet à vous je
sais pas on pourrait instaurer une fête
ce serait la fête de quoi Loïc le 11
juillet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est nul une vidéo sur les records du
cerveau cependant donc j'avais envie
d'en faire une comme ça j'espère que
vous allez apprécié ça juste avant que
la vidéo ne commence je vous le dis je
viens jouer au canal à Québec et à
Montréal fin août je vous mets toutes
les infos là à l'écran et vous allez des
liens dans la description c'est quand tu
passes au Québec ou à Montréal là cette
année fin août et après avoir discuté
avec vous parce que vous vouliez
toujours ouais tu es passé à Marseille
mais moi je savais pas ouais dégoûté
j'étais pas vu en dédicace quand tu
étais à Tours c'est quand même pas à moi
de vous prévenir vous quand je vais
quelque part en rencontre en tournage en
dédication un spectacle et vous m'avez
dit bah si tu nous préviens s'il te
plaît maintenant donc j'ai mis un outil
en place pour vous prévenir directement
puisque les algorithmes nous montrent
rien sur les réseaux de quand il faut
vous vous inscrivez en bas vous mettez
votre numéro de département vous habitez
et c'est moi qui vous envoie un mail
quand je viens en tournage en rencontre
en dédicace à un spectacle ceci étant
dit les records du cerveau loïco
générique
on se penche sur les capacités
incroyables de notre cerveau c'est ce
que je préfère parce que même si je suis
persuadé que nous sommes tous
mentalistes même vous regardez à quoi je
pense là un truc qui est sur l'eau ouais
tout à fait un bateau ouais exactement
il y a des records complètement fous qui
peuvent lui sembler une accessible mais
il y en a d'autres c'est juste une
question d'entraînement et ça ça
pourrait vous plaire peut-être créer des
vocations alors si à la fin de cette
vidéo vous chauffez pour prendre la
place d'un des champions dont je vais
vous parler déjà vous pensez à me
remercier lors de la remise des prix et
vous m'envoyez une photo l'homme calcule
le plus élevé au monde j'en ai déjà
parlé dans une de mes vidéos vous
trouverez dans la description ou pas
parce que souvent j'oublie de les mettre
mais ça vaut le coup de se pencher un
peu plus en profondeur sur son cas qui
est impressionnant il s'appelle Terence
Tao et c'est l'homme qui a le QI le plus
élevé au monde 230 alors le QI il y a
deux manières de calculer et je rappelle
quand même le QI ça ne mesure pas
réellement l'intelligence ça mesure le
QI en fait c'est tout pour rappel la
moyenne du test de QI se situe dans une
fourchette large entre 85 et 115 c'est
une grosse fourchette c'est une belle ça
serait donc le plus gros QI de
l'humanité le 162 Einstein paraît tout
petit quand même à côté Terence Tao les
australien mathématicien il a appris à
lire l'âge de deux ans ce très tôt je
rappelle qu'en général c'est 5 à 7 ans
et c'est à 50 lui justement que son père
le surprend expliqué des éléments
d'arithmétique à un enfant plus âgé que
lui et son père lui dit tu as appris ça
comment et lui dit ben c'est en
regardant la télé c'est stylé c'est un
peu flippant mais c'est stylé alors
qu'est-ce qu'il fait bah il assiste à
des cours de niveau universitaire à
l'âge de 9 ans il gagne une médaille
d'or aux Olympiades internationales de
mathématiques à l'âge de 13 ans et
termine une thèse à 17 ans et entre à
l'université pour commencer un doctorat
et puis il est nommé professeur de
l'université de California à 21 ans à 21
ans on faisait quoi nous qu'est-ce qu'on
faisait c'est évidemment le plus jeune
enseignant promu à ce rang par cette
institution le cerveau de Tarn staos est
une machine on considère aujourd'hui
comme un génie des mathématiques et il a
même développé un théorème connu sous le
nom du théorème de Green Tao alors que
les plus grands mathématiciens ont tout
au plus une ou deux reconnaissances à
l'apogée de leur carrière faire leurs
40-60 ans lui cumule déjà plus de 10
reconnaissances et pris à seulement 46
ans alors pour celui-ci on était
clairement sur du génie ça ne nous est
pas accessible avec des heures
d'entraînement pas nécessairement on a
parlé de son QI pour prendre un point de
référence je le répète encore une fois
le QI seul ne peut pas dire grand-chose
et le prochain que je vais vous
présenter lui doit rien au hasard ce
qu'il a fait tout le monde pour le faire
juste faut être très motivé quoi le
champion de calcul mental si là tout de
suite dans la vidéo je vous demande la
racine 13e de
579023 vous me dites quoi vous me dites
un truc au pif ou sûrement vous me dites
rien c'est pas si simple et bien on va
plutôt parler de notre génie de calcul
Alexis Lemaire un informaticien français
en plus qui a calculé de tête la racine
13ème d'un nombre de 200 chiffres en
gros il a trouvé un nombre multiplié 13
fois par lui-même c'est-à-dire que il y
avait le résultat et lui il a il s'est
dit si je fais tout ça à l'envers c'est
tel chiffre qu'on a multiplié 13 fois
par lui-même c'est beaucoup c'est
d'autant plus beaucoup qu'il avait pas
de papier pas de crayon et il a posé un
résultat voilà comme ça enfin ça lui a
quand même pris un peu plus de 70
secondes pour faire le compte 70
secondes un peu long quand même ce que
je veux dire c'est que je suis pas sûr
que la plupart d'entre nous on pourrait
le faire même avec une calculatrice et
tout le temps qu'on veut devant nous pas
de hasard possibles il avait une
possibilité de répondre sur plus de
393000 milliards de réponses c'est
d'ailleurs la seule personne au monde à
avoir réalisé cette exploit aujourd'hui
alors ça fait plaisir de voir un
Français dans ce classement et ils sont
chauds le français racine 13e
de tout ça 5 9 3 7 j'ai pas vous perdre
dans les détails de comment essayer pris
pour le calcul parce que vraiment vous
allez quitter la vidéo mais ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il a préparé une méthode
pendant deux ans quelques semaines avant
sa performance il s'est entraîné
plusieurs heures par jour pour arriver à
un résultat comme ça c'est bien sûr
beaucoup de travail mais il y a des
détails qu'on peut pas soupçonner par
exemple il a adopté un régime
alimentaire faible en Grèce en sucre
puisque son cerveau fonctionne moins
bien lorsqu'il mange trop de sucre notre
corps il consomme 200 g de glucose par
jour dans 130 g pour le cerveau mais pas
plus trop de consommation ça va altérer
les Synaps c'est donc réduire notre
capacité d'apprentissage et de réflexion
c'est de la performance déjà très jeune
il avait 9 ans Alexis essayait de
comprendre ce que voulait dire les
touches de sa calculatrice ce que cacher
arity Harris déjà moi j'arrive pas à le
dire lui il arrive à le faire je disais
quoi parce que ah oui ce que cacher
arrête moi ce que cacher
arithmétiquement les les touches qui qui
rendaient la racine ou le logarithme ça
ça le fascinait il dit avoir eu la
satisfaction de connaître ces procédés
de calcul puis de généraliser ensuite
vers l'âge de 11 ans il tombe sur le
Guinness Book des records où il découvre
le record du plus rapide calcul de la
racine 13e d'un nombre à 100 chiffres et
ça ça l'a chauffé c'est donc sûrement un
mélange de dons quand même de
persévérance d'entraînement et de
méthode qui lui a permis d'y arriver
même si comme il dit c'est vrai que j'ai
un cerveau qui fonctionne vite parfois
très vite mais tout le monde peut
développer des capacités de calcul
mental similaires à celles que j'ai
utilisé je veux bien le croire mais il
faut avoir envie question rapide unité
le prochain que je vous présente il a il
a pas le Time dans sa vie c'est le
champion de lecture rapide la lecture
rapide j'en ai parlé dès 2016 dans mes
vidéos c'est comme son nom l'indique le
principe d'accélérer sa vitesse de
lecture alors c'est une méthode qui est
basée sur le fait de limiter sa
subvocalisation tu sais la petite voix
que tu as dans ta tête quand tu
réfléchis mais quand tu lis tu t'entends
en fait parler dans ta tête donc l'idée
c'est de ne pas prononcer mentalement
les mots qu'on lit c'est c'est pas
simple au début et pourtant le dire dans
sa tête c'est pas du tout
utile au cerveau pour comprendre ce
qu'on est en train de lire la lecture
rapide ça permet de capter directement
le sens des phrases ça regroupe plein de
techniques je pourrais faire une vidéo
d'ailleurs un jour sur le sujet
tellement c'est passionnant pour ça vous
me le dites dans les commentaires je lis
et après je fais ou pas mais là je vous
parle de la performance de Mohamed
Koussa le champion du monde de lecture
rapide il a réussi à lire un livre de
400 pages en une heure 25 1h25 400 pages
alors bon lire vite c'est super mais
qu'est-ce qu'on retient derrière la
lecture rapide c'est pas seulement de
lire vite c'est surtout de retenir les
choses et comme dis moi-même
contrairement à ce qu'on pense plus on
lit vite plus on retient lentement il se
passe rien dans la tête rapidement on
produit des neurotransmetteurs qui
permettent de mieux mémoriser parce que
en plus d'avoir lu le bouquin de vitesse
folle il a répondu à clé des questions
des questions pièges en plus et précises
sur le sujet et sur sa compréhension et
il a eu un score de 18 sur 20 en
compréhension genre je suis pas sûr
qu'un lecture normal on retienne en
autant de choses en fait je sais que non
en général dans le lecteur normal on
retient moins de choses qu'en lecture
rapide c'est fou hein la plupart des
gens d'ailleurs pensent que on a moins
de plaisir quand on lit vite un petit
peu on pourrait comparer à un enfant qui
qui passe de marcher à quatre pattes à
marcher debout est-ce que tu as moins de
plaisir à marcher non parce que tu sais
mieux marcher tu marches correctement et
tu vas plus vite mais tu as pas moins de
plaisir que quand tu marchais à quatre
pattes c'est un peu préparé ce que moi
j'ai ressenti quand je me suis mis à la
lecture rapide mais comment on devient
champion du monde de lecture rapide et
bien au moment de devenir professeur de
l'être et d'histoire Mohamed Kusa
chercher une méthode pour gagner du
temps et assimiler des connaissances
dans ces gros ouvrages de référence
qu'il avait à lire du coup en allant à
l'atelier de lecture rapide ici émis de
façon assidue jusqu'à devenir le grand
champion et proposer d'ailleurs ensuite
ses propres formations je vous mettrai
son livre en description si ça vous
intéresse j'ai lu il est très bien parce
que oui la lecture rapide c'est
accessible avec de l'entraînement et
vous gagnerez beaucoup de temps et de
compétences en parlant de gagner du
temps le suivant c'est un délire presque
inversé parce qu'il parle beaucoup
beaucoup avant de vous le présenter vous
pouvez tenter le record le record de la
personne qui s'abonne le plus vite à
cette chaîne à trois fois vous pouvez
essayer de vous abonner d'activer la
cloche le plus vite possible 1 2 3 quoi
la manipulation
non proposition un peu forcée à la
limite allez on passe à l'homme qui
parle beaucoup c'est sur une performance
surprenante il s'agit du discours le
plus long et là vous allez me dire ouais
mais c'est quoi le rapport avec le
cerveau tu arrêtes un petit peu de nous
arnaquer avec des trucs du cerveau qui
sont pas vraiment des trucs du cerveau
calmez-vous déjà faut un sacré mental
pour faire un discours pendant 124
heures oui pendant 124 heures d'affilée
on peut dire que c'est une belle
performance je pense que c'est pas c'est
pas le genre de personne que tu voudrais
dans un repas pour dire un petit mot
durant le dîner Michel un petit mot
peut-être oh tu sais j'aime pas les
discours
mais qui commence le discours et finit à
temps 124 heures ça fait quoi ça fait ça
fait cinq jours à peu près quoi ouais ça
fait à peu près bon c'est trop il
s'appelle Louise collet il avait 62 ans
il est guide au Musée des Arts et
Traditions catalan et il a parlé sans
interruption pendant 5 jours et 4 nuits
bah oui ça compte et pour que son
discours ne soit pas trop dérangé il n'a
que très peu mangé pendant cette période
mais il parlait en même temps a commencé
le lundi à 10h et la terminer le samedi
à 14h tu as fait quoi cette semaine un
discours non mais genre tu as fait quoi
mais toute la semaine toute la semaine
c'est fou en vrai et tout ça s'endormir
et sous la surveillance quand même d'un
médecin là vous vous demandez mais il a
parlé de quoi durant 124 heures
on sent qu'il a été très inspiré parce
qu'il a parlé de nombreux poèmes et des
textes de grands auteurs qu'il aime
c'est un grand fan aussi de Salvador
Dali la longuement d'argile bercée sur
ses œuvres d'art il a terminé sa
performance presque à phone c'est-à-dire
sans voir en déclarant que c'est un
grand jour pour lui et qu'il dédie ce
record à tous ceux qui défendent la
culture et la langue catalane c'est pour
moi c'est un exploit du cerveau et
justement d'ailleurs on va parler du
record de temps s'endormir si Louise
collet est parvenu à passer 4 nuits sans
dormir ce qui est déjà plutôt phénoménal
quelle est le record sans sommeil de la
durée sans sommeil et bien c'est l'homme
qui a passé beaucoup de temps s'endormir
je vais clairement vous faire 0,6 pence
c'est l'Américain Randy Garner il a
passé 11 jours et 24 minutes bien dormir
c'est un délire une fois que son record
a été établi il a dormi pendant environ
15 heures puis il a retrouvé à peu près
son rythme de sommeil normal au fil des
jours comme quelqu'un qui serait en
plein décalage horaire cette expérience
n'est pas sans effets secondaires sur
lui c'est pas normal de se priver
d'autant de sommeil et de se bousiller
clairement le cerveau les médecins ont
constaté des sautes d'humeur des
problèmes de concentration et même des
problèmes de mémoire à court terme la
paranoïa et des hallucinations Randy
Gardner dit avoir souffert d'insomnies
graves longtemps après cette expérience
on touche pas au sommeil impunément
si si vous voulez tenter l'expérience
chez vous faites-le plutôt pas en fait
le prochain dont je vais vous parler
c'est l'homme qui est passé 19 ans dans
le coma alors là clairement on n'est pas
sur un concours on n'est pas sur une
performance que je vais vous parler
quand même de quelque chose de
surprenant en terme de record c'est
cette américain qui est resté 19 ans
dans le coma mais qui a fini par se
réveiller il s'appelle Terry Wallis et
alors qu'il avait 19 ans il est tombé
dans le coma la suite d'un accident de
voiture Terry Wallis s'est retrouvé
maintenu en vie grâce à des médicaments
mais aussi grâce votre soutien de ses
proches importants dans ce moment là et
tout au long de son coma ses proches ont
pris soin de lui sa famille par exemple
leur ramener à la maison un week-end sur
deux pendant des années ils ont fait ça
les médecins pensent que cette
stimulation a contribué à sa période
d'éveil souvent on s'imagine que une
personne dans le coma se réveille d'un
coup mais non c'est un long processus le
réveil il se fait progressivement avec
des réactions qui seront petit à petit
et qui sont entrecoupés d'autres
périodes de sommeil après autant de
temps restait dans le coma on peut aussi
se demander dans quel état il s'est
retrouvé à son réveil vous imaginez bien
qu'il s'est pas mis à parler comme avant
il a pas payé Bro ça y est je me
réveille enfin il pouvait même pas
exprimer tout ce qu'il voulait il
arrivait juste à prononcer des mots
simples comme maman les mais pas encore
de phrases construites ce qui est
incroyable dans l'histoire de cet homme
c'est que dans la majorité des cas dans
des accidents de grande ampleur des
neurones des connexions nerveuses sont
détruites sur le coup or là son cerveau
est plutôt resté intact c'est un peu
dingue et les scientifiques pensent
aussi qu'un réseau de connexion s'est
recréé entre ces neurones initieuses qui
lui a permis de parler de bouger à son
réveil même si t'es pas encore plein pot
et c'est là où on s'est dit le cerveau a
des pouvoirs incroyables et que le corps
a une capacité de régénération de fou
aujourd'hui Terrisse est décédé il a pu
vivre de belles années à côté de sa
famille et de sa fille qui était âgée de
19 ans quand il s'est réveillé parce que
lui il a vécu l'équivalent d'un saut
dans le temps en fait accident de
voiture à 19 ans il se réveille et sa
fille à 19 ans c'est vous je me dis le
il y a peut-être une vidéo en fait à
faire c'est de creuser sur ce sujet
l'histoire des personnes qui se
réveillent après plus de 10 ans je me
demande comment ils vivent ça comment il
s'adapte aux nouveaux mondes
technologies si ça vous dites moi aussi
dans les commentaires ça peut être
intéressant comme comme suite de cette
vidéo non n'oubliez pas si vous voulez
que je vous prévienne quand je passe un
tournage en rencontrant dédicace en
spectacle près de chez vous je vous mets
un lien dans la description dites-moi
les petites idées là que j'ai une vidéo
comment on pourrait faire le premier qui
met un commentaire en disant qu'il veut
les autres liker on va voir à peu près
comme ça combien de personnes veulent
ces vidéos là je crois que c'est une
bonne idée de faire comme ça je vous
mets deux autres vidéos qui sont pareils
en rapport avec des trucs un peu
bluffantes sur le cerveau si vous me
connaissez je m'appelle toujours Fabien
olicard prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt au plus tard lundi prochain à
18h comme d'habitude Ciao